hey you're garbage to work you come in a
while not new look at the busy week I
don't want to cry you go back oh hey hi
how's it going
I had a lot of blood rushing to my head
but uh it's we she's going to be really
busy because we're filming a great big
video that I'm not going to tell you
exactly what it is but this isn't one of
those empty promises because it's coming
out next week I'm not going to give too
many details about it lessons were
working so hard on it this week
won't we going to be able to get one
video out and day this week I'm sorry it
should be back to normal on Saturday if
we're all finished up by then but until
then it's just gonna be one video down
so sorry about that oh my god bye